the arguments that we just reviewed for
proofing inclusion/exclusion by looking
at how many times points are counted can
be made perfectly rigorous in fact we'll
do that in a later segment but it's
interesting and good practice to realize
that they can also be proved just from
some simple set theoretic identities
using the ordinary disjoint sum rule so
um how am I going to prove the inclusion
exclusion principle for two sets a union
B is the size of a union B is the size
of a plus the size of B minus the size
of a intersection B then the idea is
just break up of a union B into disjoint
sets because once they're disjoint sets
I can add up their sizes so if we look
at a union B a union B can be expressed
as the union of two disjoint sets namely
a the round blue circle and what's left
the points in B that are not in a so
this lighter orange colored region so a
and B Union and B minus a so these are
the points in a and these are the points
that are in B that are not in a are two
disjoint sets whose union is a union B
that means that I know the size of this
it's just the size of a plus the size of
B minus a because they're disjoint so we
conclude by the sum rule that the size
of a union B is equal to the size of a
plus the size of B minus a so now I need
a little lemma that says that the size
of B minus a is the size of B minus the
size of a intersection B if I get that
then I've proved inclusion exclusion
because now I have a plus B minus a
intersection B so we need a lemma the
lemma says that the size of B minus a is
equal to the size of B minus the size of
a intersection B so you were back to the
Venn diagram a is blue B is reddish and
the intersection recent region that
lens-shaped region is shown in purple
and we want to prove this lemma well
again um what we can do is look at UM
the set be broken up into two pieces B
can be expressed as a disjoint union of
the part of B that's in a union the part
of me that's not in a that is for any
set B and any set a B is equal to a the
B points that are in a and the B points
that are not in a covers all the cases
and this again is a disjoint Union so we
conclude immediately that from the sum
rule that the size of B is equal to the
size of B intersection a plus the size
of B minus a and then just transposing
this term for the size of B minus a to
the left-hand side of the equality I've
proven the lemma and we're done now
inclusion/exclusion for three sets we've
said before it's this slightly more
complicated thing where you've got a sum
of the of the intersections of one set
minus the size of the sizes of the
intersections of two of two sets plus
the size of the intersection of three
sets and that generalizes to the
following somewhat messy formula but
let's look at it closely together if I
want to know what's the size of a 1
through a n if I have n sets potentially
overlapping a 1 a 2 through a n and I
want their Union and I I can express the
union of them in terms of a sum of sizes
of intersections and here's the formula
let's read this slowly together so this
is a sum over every possible subset of
the indices 1 through n that's not empty
so this sum is ranging over s and it can
do it in any order it's typical to write
the the somewhere you sum up first of
all the sets of size s of size 1 and
then sum up all the sets s of size 2 and
so on but that's not necessary we just
sum in any order for every subset of the
indices the intersection
are the size of the intersection of the
AIS that are in this set of indices
specified by s so this is just the
intersection of those days that s
specifies now what's the the sign of
that of that size of intersection as we
said if it's of odd size I want it to
count positively so if I take minus 1/2
the odd size plus 1 I get an even power
of minus 1 so it comes out to be 1 if on
the other hand the size of s is even so
I'm taking an intersection of an even
number of sets then this number to the
plus 1 is odd I'm taking minus 1 to an
odd power and sure enough I'm getting
the negative sign on all the
intersections of odd size so that's what
the this rather concise but hairy
formula looks like here we have an
intersection over the AIS where the AI
is specified by the set s of indices and
I sum up these terms over every possible
non-empty set s that is the generalized
form of inclusion exclusion for n sets
all right now how do we prove this well
as lots of ways to prove it the simplest
ways to do actually by induction it's
not very hard to do by induction you
just use the to set version of inclusion
exclusion which we've proved rigorously
using the disjoint sum rule and you go
from the union of the first n sets plus
the end and apply the formula and
simplify and that works fine the only
problem with it is it's not really very
informative if you prove the theorem all
right as is frequently the case with
induction proofs you have the right
induction hypothesis the proof is kind
of mechanical but you don't really learn
much from it not always but in this case
I don't think you do a second way to do
it is by using the binomial theorem and
Counting this is a way to make rigorous
the argument that said ok we counted the
in the intersection of two points in in
the intersection of two things twice so
we had to subtract them away and then
that meant that we were not counting the
things that were in the intersection of
three not at all and so on and we've
talked through that argument
informally and I will do that in a next
segment of making that argument a little
bit more precise to prove the general
theorem and
algebra we can just look at a product of
sums and understand how it expands into
a sum of products by the distributive
'ti law and that's worked out in a
problem that is in the text and I'm not
going to do that in a video